hey guys the same day we are in Times
Square for a super fun event you would
think as evidence for sponsoring this
this is a launch of their new M&Ms
caramel flavor and this is so exciting
because before we get into all the fun
and games here let's go do a taste test
[Music]
it's not even a sense of the new
evidence caramel I've got it right here
and before we do the taste test my
question to you guys is what color is
this bag like it's the big debatable
color is the dress is it blue is it
purple I am Not sure leave me a comment
let me know what you guys think save dad
let go I guess blow this little rip off
you girl it ain't easy to say it so oh
boy
in the world
okay okay you've got our first initial
case full disclosure
caramel caramel whatever you want to
call it is my favorite flavor of all
time the first bite it taped like just
an M&M or dislike at msl popcorn chain
outer shoulding then you get into the
middle and it's like the caramel is
there and as you can tell by all the
like doing
it's super chewy no really good they're
super good so picture this guy's an M&M
caramel in the middle what do you think
it's going to taste like this absolute
it tastes like exactly so great I'm a
huge fan like my two favorite things
chocolate and caramel together in one
little single delicious treat
I keep thinking to my fingernails - girl
it ain't easy turf 800 dead body
boy that a keeper can try to do
amazingly it's all going to reality
because I mean for like all the world
around us encompasses I don't think it's
digital and crazy and actually not their
only way be you can see industry your
phone line displays three different
games from that billboard
phone line more than just do bad
everyone please
[Music]
well that was pretty cool all right
[Applause]
would be more
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you guys enjoyed this little taste
test
plus a super fun look at times where RK
that they have set up here it's really I
had so much fun let me know what you
guys think of the Eminem's caramel if
you guys try it also please like I said
before let me know how you say caramel
caramel caramel the pronunciations
[Music]
more again